das ist zu unserer reportage zum thema
stalking danke vielmals von allen
kommentar für sachliche tun wundert euch
in frage wir werden jetzt auf das paar
kommentare konkrete ego zum beispiel hat
als jessica dass sie selber schmack
biogas ag und das dieses jahr findet das
doppel immer noch ernster wird nur
werden und das salzlager schreibt dass
die personal angst oktober secchi und
bitte polizei oder meine knie endet am
anfang dann hat es aber trotzdem
schafften anzeige starte und sogar von
bosse wilke und tricks gibt es als ich
damals ende der 90er einen stalker
angezeigt habe durfte ich mir von den
kantonspolizisten sprüche anhören wie
freuen sie sich doch das den man sie
begehrt der iss hat verliebt in sie und
solange nichts passiert können wir
nichts machen also ganz ähnlich wie das
abi das anders aus dem film der fall ist
danke euch allen das alles vor dem
verzehr findet es interessant was für
unterschiedliche erfahrungen gemacht hat
wusste recherche zu dem film das opfer
werde ich wirklich aktiv stelle ist wenn
man gesagt wird weil die haben andere
möglichkeit die polizei das hat zum
beispiel doppelbedeutung als offizielle
stellen vom kanton als liedermacher
täterschaft und sie aufforderte kontakt
sind eine person was ist dass unterlagen
wenn sie das nicht machen dann würden
sie rechtliche schritte weiter und man
habe das sogar schon ein effekt und
stalking für die eu führen will
das kann zu überschreiten und auch
vorsichtige erfahrungen hand ihres
berichtet dorothea ist der stadt
schreibt
dass man geschäfte gebündelt zum stalker
in petit caux zweiter und sehr gelangt
buch zum begriff das essverhalten
seelischen schmerz verursacht hat in
konsequenz müsse schließlich bei der
polizei dass sich betroffene person in
ruhe laut und mir vorstellen dass es
extrem schmal ist wenn man abgerissen
wird und dass es extrem schwierig an
sitzung mit einem umbau
wichtig aber man daher vorher wie
wichtig dass mir findet dass man ganz
respektiert und ja ich finde es
bewundernswert ist dankbar für all das
ist so offen mit als kompliziertes der
kommentarschreiber
finde dieses verhalten unglaublich
reflektiert da stand
eine andere erfahrung berichtete die
idee und zwar seit der fussball junge
frau trainiert hat und das
einschließlich verliebtheit aufgebaut
sie hat die gefühl nicht erwartet und er
duzt jährlich eigentlich nur immer wir
erreichen mit metall geburtstagskarte
und er selber erstellt sie reagiere da
aber nichts tun
der kommentar der sozialpädagogin
koordinator park zeigt sie können den
betrag und sie meint dazu dass er sehr
lästig kann sie wenn wir bis zur
geschichte rund um den erster linie gar
nicht weg und auch schon die ausspannen
bevor es in die dritte wo die
betroffenen arbeiter belastet und stellt
auch ein ok was rund jetzt tut mir die
person vielleicht später auf und sie
empfiehlt einfach zu halten wo der
wunsch achtung takt aufgabe citigroup
dann schreibt sandra schade dass die
psychologie des dopings nicht beleuchtet
wird bei ego stalkerin scheint es ein
wahrhaftes verhalten zu sein wie wird
jemand zum stocken
vielen dank für den input und für die
frage gibt dem film heraus wirklich der
sicht von der betroffenen personen
weiter an und der täterschaft mit zu
viel rum welle gehen auf jeden fall aber
das spannende thema und völlig es vor
dem anderen film der gesetzeslage hat
einen kommentar erreicht und zwar vor
aktuelle sturz die person schreibt am
ende der doku habt ihr event dass
bestimmte gesetze ergänzt werden gibt es
davon im internet eine quelle oder hatte
diese infos bei den interviews erhalten
liebe grüße jetzt schon mal danke für
den kommentar die informationen haben
wir vor der kommission für rechtsfragen
wie genau die art von gesetz ausgewählt
das ist noch unklar im herbst ist sehr
schmal entwurf zu dem gemacht und mit
der letzten jahren tatsächlich spart 5
sind parlament geht zu dem thema zum
thema stalking die sind aber allerdings
alle abgelehnt wurde und wenn du nur
mehr weit zu dem thema erfahren eine
verlinkung mit ihr die medien metallic
zum thema stalking interview beschrieb
übrigens gz auf und 2022 möglichkeit of
electronic monitoring also das heißt es
ist ein fußfessel wurde standort
rostockerinnen festhalten damit sie sagt
der opfer nicht meint dazu es bundestag
für die stx ausgeschieden und muss jetzt
finde wenn genau die fußfessel zum
tragen und sie an zu haben
das gericht muss es allerdings oder
verbot ausgesprochen haben gestützt
darauf kann das gericht die
elektronische fußfessel nur dann
anordnen wenn diejenige person die sich
von stalking betroffen fühlt dies
explizit beantragt sie wiesen aber adolf
erstmaßnahme in jedem folgen und
verhältnismäßig sie auf weiß wo kann das
einige kommentare leicht zum beispiel
der für den airbus schiebt stalkings
härter bestraft werden foto monika monik
meint dass es wirklich schlimm dass der
gesetzgeber hier nichts macht stalking
ist in vielen anderen ländern ein
straftatbestand warum hinkt schreibt mal
wieder hinterher danke wenn man euch das
nicht kommentieren es ist tatsächlich so
dass lande und schied ohne das setzt
auch angeschaut habe in deutschland zum
beispiel ist der krise 2007 einen
eigenen straftatbestand
und ist ja sogar noch mal verschärft
wurde blues mit cyber stalking ergänzt
wurde und er steht hat sie 2006 als anti
stalking gesetzt was erlaubt ihnen
strafrechtlich zur folge und im
schlusssatz buch haben sie das so
geregelt dass es unter beharrliche
verfolgen wird jetzt doch als paar
kommentare wo beim thema stalking schuld
wieder opfer gesucht hat und auf die
macht mich sprachlos
problem aus dem nichts gemacht einfach
blocken und alles weitere auch blocken
und nichtbeachten verstehe das problem
nicht also sorry die opferrolle ist hier
nicht akzeptabel es hat ein mieter die
kommentare auf der fall vor das andere
gange sind und fragten wieso das zahnrad
an die profile wurden stalker nicht
einfach blockte die srg doch so einfach
oder das gemacht sie hat profil für
ihren stalker blockt kurz zugabe hatte
aber leider neue profil erstellt und sie
dann bitte kontaktiert mit hand der
kommentar also sozialpädagogin der
collina stolberg goes anbieter geschickt
und sie schläft als dazu das problem ist
das doppel öfters über andere profile
und kanäle versuchen kontakt aufzunehmen
das penetrante und unaufhörlicher
versuchen mit dem opfer in kontakt zu
treten ist dass die belastung aus macht
und dann er war das unberechenbare was
hund vielleicht alles nur wer steckt
hinter der belästigung würdigt
beobachtet oder wenig vielleicht bald
als nachts verfolgt seitige sache könne
die psychische und auch die physische
gesundheit von betroffenen stark
belastet und sie auf unsichere wir
finden es wichtig die fehler wie
stalking und bestrafte allgemein nicht
wie der betroffene gezählt die täter in
ein so genanntes acting claiming dazu
führen dass opfern wie das stigmatisiert
werden und dass es für sie nur
schwieriger sie hilft rolle müssen sie
flohen diego und san der opfer von
erfahrungen berichtet und für licht
können sie mit dem jahr dazu beitragen
dass doping es bitterernst ignorierte
der gesellschaft
und kann als letzter andreas luksch
liebe seid ihr bei der recherche auch
auf selbsthilfegruppen für opfer
gestoßen wenn ja wäre eine
kontaktadresse eine gute sache herr
andreas banker firma für di mi fr
wir sind leider in der recherche nur
durch aktive selbsthilfegruppe zum thema
stalking stoße aber vielleicht aber für
euch liebe zwar gerne kommentar aber mir
verlinken auf jeden fall nochmals alle
wichtigen anlaufstellen intervideo
beschrieben falls du oder reparatur
crunch gesagt wird wir sind auf keinen
fall alleine mit dem und auch hilf rolle